[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv leçon
spécial débutants avec le maître
international nino maso rasé bonjour ni
nos jours on va voir aujourd'hui un math
élémentaire très très important vraiment
il faut pas commencer à jouer aux échecs
avant d'avoir maîtrisé ce match
oui c'est très important parce qu'on
reste assez souvent avec les tours ce
soin que ça arrive ce genre de finale et
il faut connaître comment aboutir la
partie et enfin 2 donc obtenir un pont
pour pas annuler la partie gagnante
tanker donc on va voir le match
effectivement roy + tour contre euro en
maths élémentaire fondamentale vraiment
fondamental plus important que tous les
autres parce qu'il est extrêmement
fréquent il faut savoir vraiment
vraiment comment mater c'est pas évident
il faut quand même connaître la
technique
alors ici on a mis une position les
blancs ont une tour de plus une tour
face au roi noir qui est tout seul alors
pour mater avec roy plus tourner hinault
il faut s'aider des deux pièces le roi
et la tour on peut pas maté que avec la
tour non d'ailleurs on a toujours besoin
quand même le roi aussi parce qu'avec
une seule pièce même si on peut faire
faire écouler leurs parfois avec une
seule pièce comme la dent des façons
pour le match il faut ramener le roi
donc le principe reste pareil pour comme
n'importe quel final élémentaires pour
faire maths c'est à dire éliminer les
causes possibles de roide adverse 2 pour
s'échapper donc ramener vers le soin
lecointe soit les dernières rangées
donc on va amener ce roi soit vers le
coin soit en tout cas vers une rangée où
ça peut être dernière koleos et les
colombes de
n'importe où mais bien sur les bords on
va essayer de ramener sur les bords et
ses hommes dans cette position oui on va
essayer de ramener sur le bord avec par
exemple qu'on commence par tour des
seins alors à noter qu'en général il
faut mettre la tour la tour blanche ici
entre le roi noir et le roi blanc c'est
plus facile c'est de jouer autour des 1
que de jouer tourache 4 ou 3 6 ou tour
et ça serait pas très bon il faut que le
roi blanc soit du côté de la tour en
fait donc ici regardez autour des 1
et là il ya deux camps qui c'est par ici
certes ici la tour empêche le roi noir
de venir vers la et donc le roi blanc et
du côté de la tour face les deux pièces
ont cédé pour repousser ce roi vert vers
ce côté droit un grosse modo on va s'y
leur poussée par là donc ici c'est qu'on
va essayer on [ __ ] douce couleur le
cas ces 5
l'idée de cette position première étape
sur le c5 son fondation c'est ça on va
leur amener par ici ici pour le mettre
face à sor l'idée sera de faire après
donc échec avec la tour puisque c'est le
roi qui va contrôler ces cases de 2 en
face le roi noir donc ici ce roi qui
sera c5 contrôlera les trois cases ici
qui sont marqués face au roi noir donc
le roi noir qui sera un échec ici de la
tour ne pourra pas remonter et donc il
sera obligé d'aller vers là où on veut
l'amener et c'est la tour qui va faire
donc reculé et et cetera le roi à chaque
fois venir juste en face donc c'est ça
la méthode le plus classique et il faut
vraiment connaître ça donc vous voyez ça
il faut être prêt si différent de
certains finale là le roi être doit être
comme à chaque fois en face du roi parce
que si vous êtes un petit peu à côté
on va voir tout de suite par exemple
aussi mais si vous êtes un type aux
côtés comme sur celle ci s'est passé
juste en face
déjà si vous faites chier que ça marche
plus si on le roi est ici on contrôler
ces trois cases là et là des clubs
échapper aux contrôles on contrôle pas
donc si on fait échec le roi va pouvoir
s'échapper
oui on veut pas que ses chats puisqu'on
veut le repousser maintenant qu'on l'a
coincé donc pour qu'ils soient plus
simple on va commencer tout dit ou
montré par exemple vous allez comprendre
mieux donc le roi joue par exemple c'est
au noir de loi il faut jouer donc on
joue ici parce que si les noirs
sans fuyez par exemple par là on
pourrait tout de suite même gagné une
rangée en jouant tour ici et on a gagné
de ranger le roi noir encore moins
l'espace donc c'est pas la peine de tout
lutteur amené le roi si vous pouvez tout
de suite donc un péché le roi des venir
le centre et jouer avec la tour comme ça
pour nous que peu plus en plus de ranger
plus en plus des espaces
il faut vous pouvez tout de suite faire
c'est plus simple donc on joue auront
ici en maintenant il faut ramener le roi
parce que la tour tout seul on peut rien
faire sur les loyers leur échappe sur
chig leroy s'échappe si vous entends le
roi reste le centre donc il nous manque
les pièces il faut ramener la force
supplémentaire le haut à 27,6 donc les
noir e s et de rester vers le centre
parce que s'ils vont trop sur un côté de
la tour va le valais coincé à coincer ce
roi donc on va mettre maintenant le roi
blanc est par exemple ici roi le 4 est
maintenant roi c5 voilà et là c'est au
noir de jouer alors si les noirs jouent
ici
est ce qu'on va voir donc si le renoir
joue ici on reçoit la position type
qu'on a parlé ça c'est le position clé
c'est à dire c'est le très haut blanc il
ya l'opposition souhaiterait au noir il
est resté très blanche
c'est troublant juste en face d'elle
l'un et l'autre voilà et là on fait
échec avec le tour si qui oblige le roi
a remis des chèques alors regardez donc
le roi blanc contrôler effectivement
c'est rocade
la tour fait un échec donc le roi noir
n'a plus que trois cases sa disposition
tout le reste est en échec donc ces
trois cases là sont les seuls cas ce
possible alors admettons que le roi va y
aille vers ici il va se rapprocher de la
tour parce qu'il va essayer de l'embêter
cette tour évidemment il n'est pas
défendu donc il va essayer de l'embêter
pour l'instant il y avait il ya pas de
problème si que le roi et non le renoir
loin alors qu'est ce qu'on ferait le roi
blanc ici que la serre où étaient 5
c'est le meilleur cours en fait on nous
explique pourquoi est ce que maintenant
bien sûr les noirs ont toujours essayé
de rester sur cette rangée par reculer
ou même semble que ce soit obligé parce
que comme on dit s'il lui maintenant si
on suit l'on regagné l'espace avec
l'autre sens rouen gagny sinko orangé
avec la course donc c'est facile très
facile et s'arrêterait site de suite
le territoire donc ici par exemple s'ils
feront f5
on savait trop dans notre position clé
donc les rois en face et ses traits au
blanc c'est-à-dire travaux nous ont
protégés ont fait échec
et dans ce cas là regardez le roi noir
seraient obligés de venir sur une de ces
cas là et vous allez comprendre donc
l'auriculé sur le dernier un dernière
colonne s'est il y aura plus de place il
reste à voir le match où on imagine bien
on imagine bien effectivement que si si
le roi noir ici était sur la route s'est
rangé la sur un échec qui aurait match
puisqu'il pourrait plus vivre pas de
casques verts de passer la colonne âge
c'est plus de 15 ans on apparente
s'échapper sur la colonie
il n'y a pas de colonies non voilà on
peut pas donc
donc c'est ça l'idée donc les rois les
noirs vont pas jouer ce coup là
puisqu'il voit qu'ils vont être
repoussées donc ils vont plutôt jouer ce
coup là oui vous voyez c'est un très bon
coup c'est le meilleur coquelles et noir
peuvent faire puisque l'aca je fais
échec il peut s'échapper facilement
garder ses cases là sont disponibles
donc je peut m'échapper
donc est ce un échappé ça veut dire quoi
ouvert le carca centrale si c'est vous
que je ne vous souhaite pas mais si ça
vous arrive un jour restées sans tour
s'échapper ça veut pas dire que de
repartir vers le coin ou même il faut
partir vers le centre bourg
parce que dans le centre ça se bat pas
il n'y a pas de matches possibles avec
le tour si le roi arrive on reste dans
le centre exactement
donc ici donc quoi faire on peut plus
faire échec
on peut pas faire échec donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec les blancs donc
ici le plus typique c'est le roi le sur
l'autre roi
regardez vous approchez donc encore une
fois on voit pourquoi on va approcher
parce que moi on tente encore une fois
de se voir notre position clef sur 6 les
bleues noires joue ici up et cher jean
histoire échec et donc le roi blanc lui
contrôler ces trois cases là et donc le
roi qui serait là hop ne pour devrait
aller vers le vert la bande donc donc
pour les hommes à mort ne va pas va pas
venir là en fait oui donc pourquoi on
doit suivre le roi noir papa on veut
dire mais ce que vous contrôlez les
et quand ce juste en face ils sont 100
belge donc de libérer le tour de son
devoir de contrôler cette case et le
tour plus tard peut faire échec
donc ici leurs coûts et sur ses roues à
yvetot donc attention puisque maintenant
la tour est en échec
enfin et en échec et emprise du roi noir
donc comment on fait dans ce cas là on
est embêté parce que si je bouge le roi
je perds la tour alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que je fasse
et bien sûr ici il faut bien réfléchir
et surtout pas trompé ici de ne pas
partir comme quelque chose pourra par
exemple là c'est en fait n'importe quoi
parce que ça c'est sera de mettre tout
ce que vous avez travaillé à vendre pour
ramener le roi vers le coin et là ça
tombe à l'eau donc il faut rester sur le
même même colonne où ranger
parce qu'on peut avoir différents
position ça dépend où on va mais le roi
là on va partir tout simplement le plus
loin possible de roi de l'autre côté
sainte cc7 regarder on continue à
contrôler en fait la même colonne donc
on empêche toujours le roi noir d'aller
vers leur centre mais on a éloigné la
tour du roy donc on a plus de problème
combien ce cas là le roi noir qu'est ce
qui va fermer va revenir vers le centre
et là c'est au besoin de jouer oui donc
déjà arrêté une chose plus ou élus année
les tours de roi tant mieux parce que
juste pour que ça soit pas attaquable
comme mon ami latorre voyez sur le évite
le plus loin possible de renoir est ici
ou vraie marque et on est un petit peu
embarrassée parce que si on fait ce coup
on sera temps de faire ce qu en disant
on reçoit notre position clé et
attention c'est pas la même chose
pourquoi parce que c'est très haut noir
et il nous attend pas comme ça sans rien
faire s'ils vous ai dit qu'il déplace le
roi vous voyez il nous échappe on ne
peut pas recevoir même si on suit le roi
comme ça car si on fait un échec
maintenant ici hop il va s'échapper pour
réunir un petit peu en arrière quand
c'est comme ça il faut passer il faut
pas soi même se mettre en position faire
juste tout simplement content attentes
avec la tour un coup d'attentats
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un coup
d'attendre donc on va obliger les noirs
faire un mauvais coup
c'est à dire on faire tours et sète on
attend c'est à dire on atteint on bouge
pas notre roi et là vous voyez que les
gens l'obligé
à jouer oui parce que si on a transmis
un coup on veut dire comme ça on a fait
impasse entre guillemets ouais en
faisant en cours en signifiant et ça a
donné le très haut noir donc ici si
l'euro montait à 4
bien sûr là maintenant on a notre
position qu'ils ont à faire cette
fameuse et chic
on est en contrôle ces trois là donc
maintenant on peut faire échec
donc ça nous ramène même histoire qu'est
le noir aura moins en moins casse donc
le bon coup avec le noir c'est pas ça
s'est passé cette oie
yvetot donc ici encore on remarquer si
le roi par tahir à la place de
rapprocher avec le roi tout de suite
vous pouvez encore une fois entre
guillemets on dit dans beaucoup de
langues couper le couple cette colonne
voilà on utilise le mot coupé a fondé et
courtois évidemment de moins en moins de
casa ce roi noir ici donc le roi est
flou c'est le coup le plus long le roi
ici cf 2 parce que maintenant on paie
pas faire échec parce qu'il a échappé
vers le centre et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ou suit avec le roi et là il peut pas
toujours par mon temps à essayer remonte
up où il va pouvoir faire les chèques
élite et c'est quoi donc on a changé les
côtés pour le tour vous voyez parce que
quand le roi est approché à notre tour
on a juste élu année la tour la tour a
changé la place si les noirs en jour
arriva encore rapproché bon on va encore
répartir de l'autre côté pour s'éloigner
de roi noir et ça continue comme ça l'a
donc vous allez voir que c'est très haut
blanc très noir pardon donc il faut
faire rouer forme par exemple reste sur
le même que l'on est là on arrive aux
autres potions type ont fait roi des
taux jeudi pour venir là il peut pas
s'échapper par là ça c'est une deuxième
2ème position des clés on peut dire où
comme il n'y a plus qu'à se voyait soit
ils vont augmenter soit régulée leem
voilà donc la cei dont il est obligé de
saillé finalement quand ils arrivent au
bois est obligé de rome était hélas il
n'y a pas d'effets 0 voilà il ya 20 ans
mais alors là c'est leur échec donc le
roi blanc empêche effectivement
le roi noir ici de remonter peut pas et
en plus il est en échec sur toute la
rangée donc ça y est on va gagner une
rangée de plus donc le roi noir va aller
par ici par exemple pour venir embêter
potentiellement la tour et dans ce cas
là on va recommencer
oui émile de recommencer ou est
au-dessus droit edd aux basques est roi
et 3 c'est tout à fait possible mais
encore une fois on ne retombe pas dans
notre position il faut qu alors si les
noirs jouer ici hop poum échec et on
serait obligés d'amener le roi sur la
ici sur cette rangée et c'est bien
tomates et sinon le roi noir va aller
vers la tour oui aura résisté donc voilà
donc dans ce cas là on va jouer ne pas
beaucoup d'attentes
ceux qui jouent à venir là donc on va
aller vers la tour on va suivre
on est sûr parce que on s'est dit si il
joue sur le g3 on prétendait la même
position y aura échec donc il va
continuer à aller vers la tour on va le
suivre
il attaque la tour dans ce cas là on
qu'elle est là on change les côtés donc
on s'éloigne souhaitent se réforment ont
offert et flamber les cours enfin on
s'éloigne de l'autre côté le roi noir
revient vers le centre et maintenant si
on suit up le roi va nous embêter donc
il faut que ce soit al'inverse ce soit
noir de jouer donc on joue encore au
coude attend rien qu'au d'atteindre donc
par exemple tour yves 2 et maintenant si
le roi noir via angers 4 on peut faire
échec
il ya les rend nos positions et le roi
est obligé d'aller sur le côté donc il
va s'enfuir
on le suit regardez la technique est
toujours on le suit dès qu'il revient
roues en opposition et celle du racing
series 6 échecs
et toujours pareil lors on est obligé de
partir puisque le roi blanc l'empêchent
totalement de remonter donc le roi noir
a intérêt de fuir et il suffit dans ce
cas-là de continuer à le suivre jusque
ici et quand ils arrivent au bourg b il
y la part dont il n'a pas le choix
oui à partir de ce moment il n'existe
plus où j'ai neuf propositions concrètes
parce qu'il ait plus de cas d'échec ce
qui nous fait gagner la partie
tana le roi ne plus de possibilité de
s'échapper elle vous comprenez ce
histoire de coude attente c'est
fondamental beaucoup d'attentes c'est
vraiment important donc là maintenant le
roi bien ici et on refait pareil voilà
donc si le roi remonte cette fois c'est
plus une histoire des chèques mais cet
audit matt la cimade il ya plus de
colonies comme tu le disais il n'y a pas
de colonies ont regardé la cité arc
quand on est comme ça maintenant sur le
bord on contrôle ici les cases et sur un
échec ici c'est matt alors pour éviter
ça les noirs vont aller vers la tour et
il suffit avec le roi de suivre il peut
toujours pas il peut pas remonter à
chaque fois puisqu'il est mat donc une
biche et de décembre dessin là ils
attaquent la tour donc on fait la même
technique on remonte le plus loin
possible de l'autre côté rim les noirs
reviennent maintenant au centre
il n'y a pas de maths tout de suite
puisque laurent nord pourrait s'enfuir
sur cette case
déchets si par contre les tons clairs on
atteindre ce qui nous est lassé on sait
au blanc donc il faut jouer aux blancs
les blancs ne peuvent pas faire maths
donc il faut jouer un coup d'attendre si
on joue ça mais noire s'échappe
donc il faut jouer un coup d'attentes et
là les noix ne peuvent pas jouer là on a
donné le très haut a remarqué quelqu'un
en recul comme je disais et luan est la
plus impossible à tour c'est aussi
possible bien sûr au lieu de dernière
case place et avant dernière case et
attendre après oui c'est la même chose
ce n'était pas juste ne placez pas le
tour dans le centre pour l'éloigner plus
possible et c'est pas vraiment
définitive
voilà on suit ici si on remonte il ya
tout un match classique on descend il
faut redescendre encore roy et là c'est
l'heure on est obligé maintenant de
venir ici il ya le fameux contrôle du
roi blanc sur la totalité des cases de
finir roi donc on peut faire un échec et
cette fois ci c'est matt puisqu'on est
sur le bord et que au bord ici le roi
blanc contrôle comme d'habitude toutes
les classes de sortie et là ya pas de
y'a pas de colonne et fils il a fourni
une colonne pour que le roi puis ce
furent mes l'échiquier est finie et dont
ça y est c'est échec et mat
donc ça c'est le match troyes et tours
basique mais en fait alors on voit bien
qu'il est un peu long quand même parce
qu'il faut à chaque fois enlevé la tour
et c est un match beaucoup plus rapide
beaucoup je sais pas un peu rapide oui
il le rapide alors on va voir ça mais on
va retrouver les mêmes idées en fait on
va retrouver les mêmes idées on va
revenir sur la position de départ on
retrouve les mêmes idées mais on va
faire un peu plus rapide parce que là en
fait on a gagné déranger mais on va
essayer de gagner à la fois fun et on a
gagné des colonnes en fait pour pousser
le mois sur la dernière colonne mais on
va voir qu'on peut gagner à la fois des
colonnes et aussi les rangs j'ai donc
essayé de mettre le roi adverse non plus
sur une
un border chic et met carrément dans un
petit rectangle de plus en plus petit
oui alors on va voir ça et licques
sinon juste avant passé de ça je veux
ajouter petit remarque dans la variante
où on vient de voir cette mode classique
vous allez gg
j'espère que vous remarquez on n'est pas
forcément obligé commencer par tour dire
qu'on a fait mais ça pourrait être aussi
turaci ce juste pour que vous imaginez
si on pourrait aussi fait toujours faire
le même idée mais sur n'importe quelle
heure voilà on a bien le roi qui est dur
et les sillons voilà qui est du côté de
la tour donc on va amener le roi ici
comme ça devant le roi adverse et on va
encore contrôler ce sera absolument la
ministre a complètement exactement la
même chose donc la différence que le roi
a terminé au premier rang j'ai cette
fois
voilà donc sachez que sa possible sur
tous les côtés on peut le faire de tout
le côté alors là bas on veut le faire on
va le faire l'autre match on me le faire
comme ça donc on va le faire comme ça d'
entourage 6 maintenant le renoir de
bouger donc il va essayer de rester au
centre pour pas se faire mater tant
qu'ils restent au centre bon il est loin
du mat et bien en faux et faux cd avec
le roi donc pour l'instant ça rassemble
le première méthode est riche à rome
c'est pareil maintenant on ramène encore
leroy d'oran maintenant vient ici et là
on n'a pas peur de mettre les rois en
face vous allez voir pourquoi parce que
là si le roi maintenant bien mince et
leurs regards disent que la technique on
va céder avec la tour voilà on va mettre
la tour toujours pris du roi et regarder
ce qu'on va faire maintenant au lieu de
garder que des dérangés ou des colonnes
on va contrôler ce quart est donc le roi
noir déjà il est pris dans ce petit
rectangle et vous allez voir que c'est
avec l'aide de la tour et du roi donc le
rôle de roi dans cet endroit d'un set
méthode c'est juste protéger la tour
soutenir l'ado donc protéger protéger
mais aussi des qui peut il va gagner des
cases
d'abord comment ça marche alors la
regarder le roi n'en est à 2 tequila
trois coups à sa disposition il peut
aller soit sur la case ici à droite dont
jean lève tout les ici c'est l'air de
jeu durant noir en quelque sorte
il ya trois cases et en fonction de ses
trois cases vous allez voir la technique
alors si le roi nord par exemple vient à
jouer sur cette case ou sur celle ci par
exemple ici et bien tout de suite on
peut amener le roi blanc parce que laura
blanc marc déhi contrôle ici déjà des
cases et si le roi noir essaient de
s'échapper
on peut l'enfermer regardez on enferme
encore pour garder up
il est totalement enfermé dans un car
est encore plus petit donc ça va aller
très très vite en fait donc laurent
n'aura pas tellement intérêts à a reculé
comme ça parce que ça peut fermer très
vite son horizon imaginons qu'ils jouent
donc ici en face à l'euro à monter pour
empêcher le droit de monter mais dans ce
cas là on va céder de la tour regardez
la tour ici et voilà on a encore réduit
à un seul petit coup on a réduit l'air
de jeu durant noir regardez là il a plus
que ce petit rectangle de plus en plus
petit alors maintenant ou d'attentes
vous comprenez que les idées cessera
complètement là même que vous venez de
voir avec première méthode mais là ça se
passe plus rapidement grâce à cette
méthode de contrôle et plus des casses
avec la tour et une fois qu'elle aura
obtenir le faire écouler le roi on va
terminer par la même méthode
bon alors maintenant on amène le roi ici
maintenant imaginons que les noirs
jouent par exemple sous couleur
évidemment si le noir et or viennent ici
hop on gagne une rangée avec la tour
tout de suite on dès qu'on peut réduire
le rectangle on le fait si les noirs
jouent ici est bien là carrément concept
du roi voilà on se sert du roi compte
d'une tour en fait on contrôle
totalement l'espace et hors délai il a
presque plus des espaces seront noirs ou
c'est qui va alors imaginons par exemple
qu'il a ici à 8,5
voilà bien là on va faire le même petit
coup d'attentes qu'on a vu dans la foule
le coup précédent parce que regarder
c'est aux blancs de jouer et on aimerait
bien que ce soit en noir de jouer
pourquoi parce que là on me l'a une case
où on peut pas progresser puisqu'on peut
pas avancer la tour ici pour gagner de
l'espace
si on amène la tour ici le roi peut
s'échapper on n'a pas envie qui
s'échappe
évidemment donc on va jouer un simple
coup d'attendre à rester sur la même
rangée très souvent donc on joue ici et
là maintenant c'est au noir de jouer
alors disons pas de coup on est comme ça
va aller très très vite alors imaginons
que regarder si les noirs regardez même
le roi ici on a la même situation tout à
l'heure aux échecs et le roi n'en est
coincé il est obligé d'aller sur la
première rangée on a vu après comment
faisait maths c'est facile autre
solution pour les noirs c'est par
exemple y aura d imaginer que les noirs
jouent ce coup là oui en disant qu'elle
est blanc n'est pas tout de suite
contrôler on peut pas jouer ici pour
allonger puisque cette emprise et ses
emprises et bardé ya mat très vite parce
que maintenant il rend ici et regarder
tout est pris par la tour par le roi il
ya plus qu'un coup pour les pour les
noirs c'est ici et voyez bien que la
tour va faire maths ici roi ici tour là
et c'est matt donc ça va très très vite
voyez ce match est extrêmement rapide ça
c'était le coup si le roi vient ici si
le roi vient là c'est aussi très très
rapide il suffit très simplement devenir
déjà angers 6 et voilà ça y est et là
vous reconnaissez la position quand on
est de voir la première méthode
voilà qui est déjà dans une phase
dernière phase d'aboutissement on est
quasiment cessé ce la même technique si
le roi attaque la tour eh bien on va le
protéger avec le roi roi ici suffit
d'éloigner la turku d'attentes et on
peut plus remonter ici puisqu'il est roi
serait en opposition avec le match de la
tour sur ici regardez c'est matt tout
simplement
donc ça va très vite donc il reste au
roi noir
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que de
venir là pour essayer de gagner un peu
de temps échec
que faire par exemple 3 ici c'est pareil
que roy là ou encore roy ici peut-être
encore le mieux dans ce cas là il suffit
de jouer même le roi ici des qui bouge
là il suffit de jouer beaucoup
d'attentes de l'autre côté il peut pas
remonter toujours la même idée est
obligé d'aller vers le haut
on le suit alors là on retrouve la
première technique mais qu'on applique
que sur la dernière rangée avant on
pousse le roi le plus vite possible vers
le banc up rouages 7,1 ici
ensuite on le suit et maintenant sur
orge c'est tout simplement mat
vous voyez cette technique est encore
plus rapide on va vouloir faire vite le
le principe regardez donc on rejoint la
première technique donc un ont restreint
l'espace
alors non c'est tour h6 n'importe
comment d'ailleurs ça pour être sur un
côté ou l'autre côté a toujours ce qui
compte c'est que le roi et la tour sont
du même côté parents pourront c'est
juste ça retenir pour vous pas que leur
honneur soit entre les deux sinon ça
complique en fait c'est pas
catastrophique mais imaginons que si
vous faisiez tour h4 ou quelque chose
comme ça la première course sur cet
ouvrage 4b ont le problème c'est qu'elle
est nous notre roi lui même il va me
déranger
et ça ne participe pas comme il faut
parce qu'ils seront en envie de le
mettre ici voyez face au rendement sera
au lieu d'en face le roi serra des rires
en fait voilà et alors quoi voilà je
vous pensez qu'ils agissent comme ça ils
deux pièces ont eu même côté alors le
roi bouge on ramène le roi blanc faut
toujours fort amené laurent blanc on est
obligé voilà on nous ramène et
maintenant hop ça y est on enferme avec
la tour ça y est on enferme le renoir
il ya un grand espace encore mais vous
allez voir qui vous avez vu qui ça
réduit très vite par un endroit là hop
on ramène le roi
regardez comme le roi déjà empêche
laurent nord de bouger donc par exemple
ou f3p des temps de faire ça c'est le
droit ici on va faire froid ici et là
par exemple simplement un coup d'
atteinte ou d'attentes
il faut qu'il faut bouger avec son roi
si on vient ici par exemple on peut
faire un échec et le roi s'échappe pas
vraiment parce que si il va là il a un
tout petit espace sa disposition
voyez donc où il va quoiqu'elle à quel
que soit l'endroit où il va il ya un
petit espace par exemple droit
ici il suffit de ramener le roi en le 5
sur wave 3 on gagne du terrain avec la
toque et cette fameuse carré donc on
retrouve ont gardé wii commence a
rétréci tout à l'heure et il avait plus
été plus des places et leur dire il ya
plus de 10 par rapport à tout à l'heure
ça va très vite et le roi est plus en
plus un prisonnier suroît ici par
exemple tout de suite en mai le roi up
contrôle de la tour aussi par des il a
plu beaucoup de cazin le pauvre au roi
ci s'échappe par là il peut tenter de
s'échapper par là mais vous allez voir
ça va très vite parce que s'il va ici
échec alors s'il descend il est toujours
il est sur la première rangée suffit de
ramener le roi henri iii pour protéger
la torre a pressé le mode classique et
leur silva à la en disant je m'échappe
il s'échappe rien du tout parce qu'il
suffit de jouer un petit coup d'attentes
et regarder la tourmente est simple
c'est que signifie qu quoi qu'il fasse
et le match sur le costume en un jour on
ici et là ça y est c'est le fameux match
classique
combien de voir toujours pareil le roi
blanc c'est comme ça qu'on fait maths
avec la tour l'europe la empêche le roi
noir de monter et la tour fait le mat
sur la dernière rangée la dernière
colonne voilà
que vous avez les deux techniques la
première technique c'est la technique
longue oui mais qu'il faut connaître
notamment plus classique que j'imagine
ils ont commencé par première méthode
peu après ils ont découvert encore
remboursé donc soyez aussi prudent de
faire les courses précis parce que à
savoir que dans les échecs il ya les
règles particulières de nuitées c'est à
dire aussi il existe faire match nul
part en longueur de coûts c'est à dire
dans cette position attention si vous
n'arrivez pas fermes atteint 50 coups de
l'adversaire peut réclamer la nul voilà
donc donné il faut pas que vous voilà la
règle aux échecs c'est que quand on peut
quand il évoque le mouvement de pions
oui c'est d aucune prise de pièces ce
qui est le cas là puisqu'on n'a plus que
la tour nous on n'a que cinquante
groupes pour mater donc sinon c'est nul
pourquoi cette règle parce qu'on
pourrait rester toute la nuit peut-être
rien une nouvelle cadence on sait qu'on
appelle cadence fischer aux échecs up
souvent ou quand on fait le coup il nous
ajoute 30 secondes par coup donc s'il
n'est pas de cette règle et si quelqu'un
s'amuse jean même peut-être fait une
blague je sais pas où la rhubarbe urmatt
ça peut durer toute la nuit et c'est
donc il fallait poser quelque chose
limite à cette position donc 50 courses
et pas très très longue aussi on choisit
les coûts pas forcément correct donc
fait attention de ne pas trop traîner
les pires en privé donc si vous
appliquez là l'autre méthode en général
ça rentre peu à peu près d'en voir entre
quand vint coup arriver aussi dans cette
position nous on vous placez la position
la plus difficile où le roi noir et déjà
centralisée voilà qu'il se trouve dans
un autre parti
quand vous passez dans cette position le
roi sera déjà vers le coin bien sûr que
vous arrange
donc ça va encore raccourcir l'averse ça
va terminer dans dix coups par exemple
ou me voir sept coups donc n'ayez pas
peur mais juste il faut pas non plus que
vous vous promenez à 4 tours 5 vous
précis alors tout cas ce qu'on vous
conseille vraiment c'est de vous
entraîner à faire ce matin on vous a
vraiment donné les deux techniques
essentiellement la deuxième technique et
la plus rapide mais apprenez d'abord la
première avant de passer à la deuxième
qui
qui est un peu plus technique mais la
deuxième est la plus rapide à un moment
vous pouvez faire maths dans toutes les
positions en quinze coups maximum donc
vous pouvez apprendre un ferme at fait
le test et le contre l'ordinateur contre
vous-même aussi c'est contre vous mais
ça me paraît un peu bizarre mais ça
marche très bien aussi testé c'est tout
seul voilà et apprenez à le faire vite
rapidement et comme ça ça deviendra
naturel et vous serez plus de questions
est vraiment fait le parce que sinon il
ya beaucoup beaucoup d'amateurs qui
perdent ou qu'ils arrivent pas finir des
partis parce qu'ils savent pas mates et
ça c'est bien dommage parce qu'ils ont
gagné du matériel il n'arrive pas à
finir la partie ce serait là il suffit
que vous réjouit cette position tôt fois
maxime valette trois fois je crois et ça
va ça va devenir très naturel pour vous
de faire les maîtres pareil séparant le
problème c est facile petit entraînement
très utile pour gagner vos premières
parties d'échecs
vous pourrez surprendre votre papa votre
maman votre cousin avoir votre voisin
enfin de tous les gens avec qui vous
allez pouvoir jouer une belle partie
d'échecs voilà merci nino pour ce pour
cette leçon sur le match fondamental
numéro 1 sans doute aux échecs vraiment
à connaître vraiment vraiment sur le
bout des doigts ce match roy tour contre
roy qui est très très très très souvent
une conclusion des parties d'échecs
merci beaucoup et à bientôt pour une
autre leçon défèque sur diagonale tv
merci et au revoir
[Musique]